this is great what what a cool thing to
do it's funny we always start these
things all of these interviews with it
basically be like a tech run-through
everyone's like so how do I my framing
up properly and you gallery view is the
key and it's kind of fun to see into
everybody's homes but I mean how long
has it been since you guys have all
actually gotten together like this
unzoom yeah one of them just walk by
they're so used to just walking in the
middle of everything and be like anymore
it's just like the cat the kids
everything's yeah but it's been it's
been what 15 or so years since the show
ended have you guys kept in touch some
of us a book yeah I have seen I have
seen everyone here yeah in the last 15
years and in fact I have seen pretty
much everybody in the last year I would
say jacket may have been a little longer
since we worked on that movie together
yeah yeah everybody in the last year bro
I think you were my last restaurant
lunch before yes I had LA end of the
world lunches that we did know it was
the week of the elbow bumping it's yeah
it's a I mean obviously the greats we're
all living in the strangest time right
now two months in I was redoing the show
and I think an episode one right away
there's like a SARS reference like you
guys are talking about are you just
coming off of SARS I would have strange
sort of coincidence that you know that's
a real thing that happened during the
SARS thing which which
sort of took a was a major blow to the
industry in Canada and we sort of
weirdly escaped that that's a weird
that's like a weird thing that we
escaped and and to go through it to have
this come back like 20 you know almost
20 years later and see it's sort of curb
all of our you know to make us think
about how essential making TV shows is
or isn't is a weird thing to kind of
revisit almost 20 years later you know
yeah when I think about the show when I
think about train 48 I think about the
way that people hold Canadian shows like
near and dear to their heart you know
being like you guys are all known for
doing the show that was like a time I
remember seeing it and being like whoa
look they can do this entire show on the
GO train like the whole thing is gonna
take place all these conversations on
the train back and forth and it seems so
rather than time but it worked you guys
won like three hundred plus episodes on
this thing didn't you update all our
IMDB pages okay because that's the
problem if you go in I maybe it looks
like we were on two episodes or three
episodes someone has to go input
everybody's like 197 that was so because
then it'll look really impressed yeah do
you brought all your passwords
villainous or just so much
deeply because they saw them so often
and it was really entering into I
wouldn't I I guess it was a soap opera
but can I say yeah I've never
experienced anything like that since
like we're just I was like you're on The
Daily Show with Sam B I mean that's a
controversial show you're on now and you
got I'm not starting my day by making
out with Robin Asia and that's I'm sorry
I'm sorry I have that experience every
day it was also like that one of the
first shows to have like I mean they
really pushed having an online presence
which back then was not a was it was a
very new thing and we and I remember it
like after our first week of shows going
to like the message boards and looking
for my character's name and I think the
first comment I read just said I don't
know why I just hate his face like
that's what you get 99% of the time on
the internet if you go to youtube
comments or Twitter and I see those were
ahead of the curve I mean in so many
ways it didn't feel revolutionary at the
time because not only was it the idea of
the setting but also and I know how true
this was but entirely improvised it was
the show or like the Jasmine script and
it was that's what our there were
writers who kind of gave kind of an
outline at arc so you knew what you were
gonna have to cover over that period of
time but how you said it how your
character said it that was up to us yeah
there was no written dialogue just a
synopsis of your character who you're
sitting with that day what the arc of
you know those the character and the
scenes that day but yeah and in essence
we sort of became writers as well
because
you would do a few takes and the
director would come along and be like
that was great say that again you that
was good that response was cool let's
keep that let's go again that was very
progressive about the show was was that
we were dealing with issues that other
shows weren't we Dell we had a we had
someone who was transgender so long
before we're even talking about that
about gay marriage but like all sorts of
things and I think that's what made it
so unique and and fantastic yeah and
also at least I remember people running
onto the set with a newspaper like if
something was truly happening that day
we would cover it we'd say oh that
that's happening right now we need to
mention it because we were supposed to
be right like in the moment and that it
wasn't it was ahead of its time it was
interesting for each of us that had
political persuasions either way you'd
have to sometimes play the opposite of
what you you know personally believe
then you'd have to riff on something you
know totally out of your comfort zone I
mean you know Pete Raul was you know
famous for that because he'd always be
harping on the right-wing kind of on the
way but he's I mean considering I'm a
communist yeah
your characters were so well developed
and so distinct like right off the bat
from the moment you met them
people could sort of connect to oh I
know something like that or I am someone
like that and I want to talk a bit more
about the about the process because from
the beginning of the show to where you
guys were I guess two years in when you
were shooting you you know 300 some odd
episodes it must have gotten smoother
over time I'd know Ilana if you can
speak to what it felt like coming in to
the show with all these people that had
sort of kind of maybe they figured out
where all their rhythms were and what
everybody else's rhythms were yeah
clearly because everybody already had a
relationship so it was like and because
our improvising it really did feel like
you were I wasn't playing myself but you
were playing at you know how do i how do
I fit in on the first day of school and
also these guys are such so good at
their craft and excellent comedians at
that so it was always trying to find a
way into the story but when we as Lisa
mentioned there would be like a bit of a
story arc and you go it was very early
in the morning I was always like how are
these guys my names were hopped around
this is six o'clock in the morning and
I'm talking to a producer going yeah she
had a hard night last night and who
she's totally hungover so she's gonna be
a bastard this morning and then we would
like honest he was like guns blazing and
the day was wrapped I think by like 1:30
yeah I would love to do a job like this
again where you hear you get to see the
show that night it was a really special
it was a really special time in a really
special show and I'm kind of shocked
that no one has really done it again
yeah what does even I remember the
summer where we began do it it was such
a unique process with your creators with
your writers with your whole production
team the cameramen they were a like a
part of this show and all of us begin to
know each other so well it really it's
unlike anything I've ever done in my
life it was pretty special time yeah I
it's funny when I would tics I would
take the train when you guys were doing
the show like that was my thing I
commute by GO train and I would sit
there and I would go I kind of wish I
had a group of people to talk to you way
to deal on the show and I would just
kind of follow space what I would find
them maybe miss my stop or whatever it
is how do you think how do you think
this show would translate to mm about
2020 I don't know who's on the train
right now but like in a modern
times people are really not really
chatting with each other now like if I
ever take the train you know these days
people just on their phones the entire
time you'd but it'd be like a half hour
of people just on their iPhones well I
think the hardest thing to do would be
to to buy them looking up from their
phones I know that my biggest struggle
when we started the show was finding a
way into why do I talk to any of these
people you know I was young younger than
anyone by maybe 10 years and once we got
into it it was great and you built these
relationships and everyone bought it but
from the beginning I really struggled
thinking well why what would why would I
why would I you know and so I think that
would be the biggest struggle that being
said I think after you get them up from
their phones I think people would find
it very cathartic to watch a group of
strangers not look at their phones for
half an hour and deal with each other I
think that's maybe even more prescient
and more impactful now than it was that
in a way yeah there is a certain
innocence to that the show in that way
mm-hmm you know that we are all talking
to each other and having relationships
and so to your question cross I wouldn't
would it translate today I don't know
what do you think I don't know cause
like I whether or not they were actually
trying to capture a picture of reality
we kind of let that go pretty pretty
quickly into the process I feel like we
all just kind of like bought into this
idea of that okay we're just gonna talk
about stuff and it's gonna be a lot more
engaged than it ever was even before
there were smartphones and stuff so I
don't know I think you know it can work
and we just kind of play along and
assume that we put the phone down for a
second and start chatting to somebody
and I mean when we got started getting
into tasers and stuff there was a wink
that you know we were going into what we
were just gonna have a party no matter
what they did you guys get an outline
for an episode and and look at and go
how am I gonna work around this like how
am I gonna get a dizzy
no I mean the writers were amazing they
really envisioned this and you know you
know that the producers they envisioned
this kind of plan for these characters
that stretched over all these episodes
so they had a great master plan but just
because you know like anything if you
get a script in a regular TV show
sometimes you're looking at the dialogue
and they're like oh man how am I gonna
say this in a way it wasn't that
different because we'd have a plot that
we'd have to execute but we'd have to
come up with it but I think one of the
the parts about the job that made it
amazing was because you are asking the
actors to make up the dialogue you are
also asking the actors to invest in it
in a way that's never been like any
other TV show I've been on because we we
took it all quite personally because we
were helping come up with each every
episode every word was coming from each
actors own you know imagination and I
think that's kind of what made it so
cool okay lazy actor cuz it's like I
can't mess scripts now I like like just
whatever line I said was gonna be the
right line I don't have to remember eyes
like where I am on the page and wait for
somebody else I have a response instead
you're just responding emotionally they
have an emotional response yet emotional
response back rather than what was the
word was it was a Devastator decimate
words to intention is like just an
amazing acting exercise that we had to
do every day for two years I mean for me
it was like theater school I never went
to theater school but it was yet we got
up at 4 o'clock every morning and we're
just asked to put words to the
intentions of what you were going to do
which is you know a great way to break
down a script it's a great way to - and
you have to do it you know every morning
and have it be on television and sound
natural and I mean it was an it's an
amazing acting exercise the same day it
aired which is when does that it's so
wild remember that no you krysta the
Penelope Booton house our director shout
out to them and Ron Murphy and all their
men but I remember Penelope was really
key to us saying we don't actually
say everything so what are we not saying
enjoy she was really big on that she's
like we're saying everything so we have
to have those moments when we're
restraining ourselves and not saying it
was really right but if I ever tried to
do that they'd come up and be like hey
man how you feeling today I got a sense
that your character operated with a
different set of rules than the rest of
us oh yeah you were allowed to get away
with so much which was amazing I mean it
was great but it was like the whole it
was that sort of that world of Homer
Simpson except it was it was you know
John McLoughlin outrageous things and
well that's Johnny the ground up that's
like the expectation was built in early
on and then it was like there you go
that's what I got a that's what they
expect every time it's like you know
whether it felt natural or not at times
it felt like too much it's what they
wanted every time it's what the director
is right it was like all right but
that's that's what a sitcom and a soap
opera is - right I think overly
sometimes that would be hard for us
because you'd want the characters to
really change you did 318 half hours and
you feel kind of like the person's doing
the same thing over and over again in a
movie you know you're supposed to change
and transform by the end but in a sitcom
or a soap opera like people are watching
it to see you deal with a new situation
in a different way but you don't really
change and so I know that's what drove
me nuts is I go oh my god but didn't I
already do this in like episode 60 in an
episode 142 and and then over time you
started to realize okay well you just
kind of that's sort of your job but
people are watching to see oh how is he
gonna deal or she gonna deal with this
situation you know this time I remember
saying hey can I do something funny
Thank You Liz annoyed they just and I
was like no that's my job
it just needs to be in a way she's
annoying so yeah it's true what role is
saying y'all we all had our role in
their madness
there was only one dressing room that we
all had to put a camera in those
dressing rooms cuz there was some good
there was some gold goin on every inch
of rolls just we always Lee would admire
the different types Mrs Murphy had that
they are a pin or a scarf you're like oh
this is nice today
were there any anything from the from
the set or wardrobe two guys cat there's
a s keepsakes did you might still look
at today yeah Miranda Murphy stapler I
have like a thousand of these for some
reason yeah that's all you look like
Shakespeare in that picture like it's so
funny was that the first game you Madame
is that the second shoe that's the
second
well I have those remaining down the
tracks yeah yeah I don't wanna be on
ease hats
I'm sorry idly 193 episodes souvenir
sweatshirt okie I've been wearing in an
epidemic I still have some of the
scripts
I saved the first script from day one I
have copy of the contract is anyone paid
if anyone's been paid but I don't think
they could have really gone with the
whole kitchen like like had like iron-on
sweatshirts of like the different
characters like you know would like the
star is kind of the 3d stars coming out
around there like with the sparkles and
like just gone full kitchen with like
Krista you know we're not Krista what
would your character's name but like
like the stars coming out I don't know
just fully good all shooting for two
years pretty much straight right like
it's a lot of it must seem like a blur
you've got some very like very distinct
memories of of your time but did you
ever think I mean a show that goes on
for that
is gonna be embedded in the memory of
Canadians and so when you think about
that show does those things connect for
you that you guys were part of something
and not completely dissimilar to Grassi
that you guys mentioned but people know
it and it's a touchstone for them is
that do you think about that at all I
mean I don't think it's lost on any of
us I know that even at the time I don't
remember a single day going by when
someone didn't talk about how weird and
wonderful a job it was you know it was
it was so different and and special and
unique and had never been done and we I
think maybe part of what people
connected to was that they were watching
us not just make up the dialogue but
make up a style of show that that we
didn't know how it was gonna work they
didn't know how it was gonna work I mean
I it's it was so special to us I think
because you know as actors you don't get
often get jobs for not just years at a
time but also full years at a time like
going to work every day with the same
people and and you know people got
married and broke up and and kids were
born and you know it was an extremely
important and amazing time and for for a
group of actors to stay together that
long it's kind of unheard of and hang
out with each other all the time it was
we even went to Barbados and liked it
and everybody came to my wedding cuz I
got married that that first summer
everybody you know the cast the crew and
it was such a rare and unique experience
I would honestly it I will never forget
it was so much fun I hadn't done a lot
of film interview at that point so that
you know the years following I think I
started to really realize how unique and
amazing of a show it was you know and I
just kept one eye wanting I wanted that
experience over and over and over and of
course it's not but it was it was a
great time it was yeah and you guys keep
up with with each other's careers
they've been falling along you are your
cheerleaders for each other of course
absolutely yep Paul D Pauly bought me
lunch last summer because he's busy with
but Paul he's on Kim's convenience so
he's got tons he's probably the only one
of us who's got like real
so he bought me lunch and eat try to get
him to buy you lunch just the thought I
was at a hot Leafs game and Paulie was
on the screen that's how I knew finally
I was like paulie's dig now see like his
a four story picture of his face every
time I come up from teaching my classes
know I'm here it's just I'm dying of
embarrassment that's all ya know it's
very kind of you guys thank you I don't
take compliments very well so it's uh ya
know it's it's been a crazy ride and you
know trade 48 is still uh it means so
much to me because I learned so much
from working with all you guys I learned
to be present
I learned to be smart quick on my feet I
learned to be a better person you know I
made some great friendships with you
guys and I carry that with me and I
tried to use those lessons that I
learned in everything that I do when I
work on a set and so you know I'm in a
very enviable and very fortunate
positioned to be working right now and
honestly I wouldn't be here if I hadn't
learned all this stuff and been friends
with all of you guys and so it's I very
much appreciated the time that I spent
on train 48 was some of the best times
in my life oh right on Paul